ausgerechnet in dem Moment macht schon
Schnittbild
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
es wird mal wieder Zeit für einen für
Sommer es wird mal wieder Zeit wie ist
es immer wieder Zeit für so wieder Zeit
für da gibt's doch ein Song oder irgend
irgendwas gibt's doch
noch im Kopf wahrscheinlich okay es wird
mal wieder Zeit für einen schönen
Rührkuchen einfach so ein Sonntagskuchen
wisst ihr was ich meine wenige Zutaten
vielleicht auch Zutaten die man schon da
hat wenn man gerne backt und kocht und
deswegen heute ein Kuchen aus der
Rehrückenform wenn man diese Form
gemacht aber
ich muss sagen der Rehrücken der
klassische Rehrücken an sich das ist so
ein Kuchen der hier drin gebacken wird
sondern wird es ja gestürzt dann kommt
eine Schokoladenglasur drauf und es
werden dann ganz viele so kleine
Mandelstifte drauf gepickt ich muss
sagen so ein klassischer Rehrücken der
gefällt mir optisch gar nicht so gut
aber ich finde trotzdem die Form richtig
schön weil es eine etwas kleinere Form
ist als ein Kastenkuchen und halt so
eine schöne Rundung und man kann damit
mega kreativ werden deswegen habe ich
mir heute gedacht machen wir einen Mokka
Kuchen also einen richtig saftigen
Schokoladen kaffeekuchen wenn ihr keinen
Kaffee mögt dann bitte einfach weglassen
und durch Milch austauschen dann habt
ihr einfach einen saftigen
Schokoladenkuchen und wir können ja von
Schokoladenkuchen nicht genug bekommen
deswegen hier einmal den Zutaten für
euch dafür verwende ich 4 Eier 100g
Zucker etwas Salz und Vanilleextrakt
einen Espresso das sind 40 ml 100 g
Zartbitterkuvertüre 100 g Butter
100 Gramm Mandeln die sind bereits
gemahlen 75 Gramm Mehl plus Backpulver
oder in den backmehl und einen Teelöffel
Kakao das war es schon jetzt gebt ihr
hier den Zucker wow das sind die Eier
gibt die hier die Eier den Zucker das
Salz und Vanilleextrakt in eine
Rührschüssel und dann alles schön
schaumig verrühren
[Musik]
dann könnt ihr hier schon mal die Butter
auf dem Herd schmelzen oder auch gerne
in der Mikrowelle dann den Herd
ausschalten dann rühre ich nämlich die
Schokolade und den Espresso ein damit
sich die Schokolade schön auflösen kann
ausgerechnet in dem Moment machst du
einen Schnittbild
sag mal so eine richtige so eine
c-bar-werbung machen okay mit einem
Wisch ist alles weg ist immer gespannt
nein ja aber dann ist es wahrscheinlich
eine Marke das ist wahrscheinlich
zwieba mit zwiebigen ist alles weg
wundervoll sieht es aus schön cremig da
kommt jetzt die Schokolade rein und auch
die übrigen Zutaten und dann wird alles
kurz verrührt
[Musik]
sieben aber Kakao schon
wow
[Musik]
jetzt die Backform mit backtrennspray
einfetten und das ganze einfüllen und
backen
bisschen zu schaumig gerührt hier
mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir die sally hat
so gut gemeint mit schaumig rühren und
der Teig geht bislang auf
jetzt die Frage Bauchgefühl darauf hören
ein bisschen rausnehmen
oder no risk no fun
wenn du so frägst nur von
ich meine da ist mein backmehl drin ihr
wisst schon wie gut es aufgeht
jetzt packe ich den herein
das ist so wunderschön
[Musik]
der Kuchen ist gebacken und er ist nicht
übergelaufen die Menge war perfekt ich
habe ihn jetzt auch abkühlen lassen und
gerade hier auf und abkühlter gestürzt
zeige ich euch gleich jetzt gibt es noch
eine Mokka Glasur wie gesagt wenn auch
ihr hier keinen Espresso wollt dann
lasst den Weg und nimmt stattdessen
Sahne 40 g Sahne 40 Gramm Espresso 160 g
Zartbitterschokolade und dann wird das
ganze noch dekoriert und ich denke ich
nehme dafür diese crispress das sind so
kleine Kekse mit Schokoladenüberzug
richtig gut als erstes wird jetzt die
Sahne mit dem Espresso aufgekocht dann
das ganze vom Herd runter nehmen und die
Schokolade einrühren
oh schön schön sieht's aus hier
okay dann kommt jetzt Thekla so da drauf
[Musik]
ich komme jetzt noch ein bisschen Kakao
nimmst drauf Kakao das passen nämlich
auch gut und die crispyros
und dann kann ich es auf eine schöne
Tortenplatte setzen und wir probieren
den Kuchen
am besten mit einem coffee
[Musik]
okay
ist das Soft
und weich
oh der ist so schön der ist so weich
hört ihr das hörst du das
wow oh mein Gott
hier das ist für dich
ich weiß es ist ein großes Stück aber du
schaffst es schon
sie schaffen das schon
[Musik]
und dann im Abgang
so Kaffee und Kuchen ist eigentlich
meins aber der ist lecker oh ja ich mag
eigentlich auch keinen Kaffee im Kuchen
aber da drin ist das schon richtig gut
die Glasur muss ich sagen TOP Glasur
wirklich sehr sehr gut richtig leckeres
softer weicher saftiger Kuchen
den gönnen wir uns jetzt alle nicht oder
ja den schaffen wir den gönnen wir uns
mit zwei mischaufe denn Kuchen oder naja
naja das Rezept gibt es auf
sallys-blog.de in meiner App und ich
würde sagen probiert ihn einfach gerne
mal aus wenn ihr weitere einfache
richtig easy peasy
rührkuchenrezepte haben wollt dann
schreibt es mir gerne ich muss sagen ich
glaube bei mir waren sich voll die
Erkältung an heute morgen ging es mir
echt noch besser und jetzt merke ich
richtig meine Augen die drücken
ich muss jetzt ins Bett
mache ich eh nicht aber ich hole mir
jetzt einen Tee legt die Füße hoch und
kommentiere eure Kommentare das mache
ich jetzt mal so ins Bett legen wenn ich
noch nicht müde bin das kann ich nicht
also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken bis zum
nächsten Mal ja okay nach dem Stück
Kuchen okay darf ich noch mal Gabeln ja
du darfst noch mal Gabeln
[Musik]
und
ja sehr gut
ach ist das schön das
da ist jeder Schnitt ein Kunstwerk
das sind so Kuchen
da könnte ich einfach Vorfreude weinen
weil es mich so berührt
aber vielleicht ist auch die Erkältung
die aus mir spricht kann auch sein
ich nehme im Bett
[Musik]